Le lundi de Pâques est une journée unique,
la seule du calendrier à bénéficier d’un tel statut.
C’est le seul jour férié de l’année que rien ne justifie.
On ne commémore aucune victoire,
aucun événement national,
on ne célèbre aucune fête religieuse.
Le lundi de Pâques, il ne s’est absolument rien passé.
Alors pourquoi ce jour est-il férié ?
Il faut remonter au Moyen Âge pour trouver la réponse.
A cette époque, il n’y avait pas que le lundi…
Pâques le lundi…
La semaine entière était chômée.
Cette période, baptisée l’octave,
était consacrée aux pèlerinages.
Une sorte de « capsule de déconfiné ».
Comme les gens se déplaçaient à pieds,
il valait mieux prévoir large.
C’est Napoléon Bonaparte qui a sonné le glas de l’octave
en réduisant cette période au seul lundi de Pâques.
Si vous avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir
les vidéos précédentes
en cliquant sur les côtés en haut ou en bas
j'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour .
Pour être sûr de n'en rater aucune
vous pouvez vous abonner et activer la petite cloche
Allez à demain et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste lien